[Music]
thanks for being here I'm impressed your
your people showing up the other at
fireside chat was kind of scaring me
that everyone would just avoid this
session but no it's great to have you
here and this talk is about art so
there's a part of this talk which was
supposed to be on garbage collection
that my colleague David was planning on
giving but we're not gonna rehash the
same thing so I'll put long pauses
awkward ones I hope during the talk so I
can fit the 40 minutes so bear with me
so given we're celebrating 10 years of
Android given I thought it would be a
good idea to think about what we've done
the last 10 years and how the end of it
run time which is the thing we worked on
for a couple of years now evolved so
here we are so some of you went to the
chat stalk so I guess you already know
what the what an Android runtime is in
the Android stack but in case you don't
it's that little layer that yellow one
here between the android framework like
the Android operating system and the
actual underlying kernel the runtime
runs both the android framework and all
of the apps select everything written in
Java that's what we execute and so being
so core in the platform it becomes
responsible for a ton of things like the
exhibit the user experience would be
very very bad
if the other word of our time was not
efficient and you started this morning
with how the GC was sort of kind of poor
in the top of days so in this talk I'll
show you over time how runtime versions
that like the old iterations we've made
over the past they've oscillated between
okay why do we need to
move for this year and like I said art
that would work time is possible for a
bunch of things and raw performance is
one here one like how fast we execute
Java code but clearly it's also
responsible for jank right like the 16
milliseconds window if the runtime is
not able to execute the Java code of
that I of the app well then we'll miss
the frame and produce a lot of junk
application startup there's a lot of
Java code it needs to be executed during
application startup again if the runtime
is slow startup will be slow good times
the inroad OS is written in Java so a
lot of code again executed during boot
battery if we're slow we're going to
tank your battery and install time is
also something we care about because we
are when we get an apk the platform will
optimize it and that could take a long
time depending on how we implement it
and we don't want that long time to
happen because we want you to use the
app by the way and the other two which
is like memory related is like this
space it's like how much space is the
runtime taking for its own optimizations
and then RAM so Java being Java there's
allocation that the runtime needs to
handle and if it doesn't do it well then
it can take a lot of RAM so this is
essentially there's been three
incarnations of the Android runtime the
first one was dalvik it was the first
implementation that shipped with Android
and albert's dalvik purpose or dalvik
main focus was how do we save RAM and
the reason being back in the days like
10 years ago the RAM we had on the
phones were shipping was like even less
than 200 megabyte and that was very
little if you want to execute the whole
event the Android stack so everything
dalvik was doing was
about okay how do we save on RAM so it
could not generate any code Jade or IOT
is how we generate code it could just
interpret the text code the tax code
being the thing that gets sent to the to
Android for execution of your app
eventually it got a just-in-time
compiler so that we could generate
native code of the Dex code but again it
was very limited to what it could do
because Ram was the main focus and it's
GC was tailored for a apps should not
allocate objects if you've been to the
talk this morning things have changed
but back in the days the recommendation
was like please avoid allocations and
this worked well for I think five years
till I killed KitKat but it was like a
point where like dalvik could not keep
up phones were getting bigger phones
were getting more performance more RAM
like mm that was 2013-14 I think it was
one gig two gigs of RAM and apps were
also getting bigger so initially apps
was supposed to be like this small layer
between UI and the framework but apps
become started doing a lot of more and
more things so that 16 millisecond
window I talked for rendering the frame
well more things started to be executed
there so we had to do something about it
and the answer happened in lollipop with
art which introduced ahead of time
compilation
so no more Enterprise interpretation or
it very very little and most of the
things were ahead of time compiled
meaning we were executing native code
for your app and that is like probably
20x faster than interpretation we also
introduced like a state of the art GC
what you find in regular run times of
being precise
means we're not gonna be confused by an
integer that looks like a like an object
but also generations so that the GC
pauses we need to do in the UI thread
will be very short
so pauses don't actually end up creating
jank the third incarnation is like an
evolution of art it happened in two
releases like Angeline Dugan Android or
Rio in Android nuga we introduced
profile guided compilation I'll talk
about this later or explain a bit later
what it is but it drastically helped on
scaling arts ahead of time technology to
to be more optimized for the full
platform the profile guide compilation
has underneath the way it works is like
it's a hybrid just in time ahead of time
compiler so trying to use the best of
both worlds to optimize the platform and
you know after we've done all of some
optimizations in N in all we focused on
the garbage collector and implemented a
brand new one which makes the pause even
shorter on the on the UI thread we call
this current GC now the the older GC
happening happen the GC happens on a
different thread so it's not affecting
the execution of the app alright so
before I dive in into our details I
wanted to show this to you like the
state of Android distribution today and
in case you're still optimizing for
dalvik or if you need to care about
dalvik and this is just annoying GC for
alloc if you've been a church talking
than what I'm talking about
well there's still just 10 percent here
10 10 plus KitKat jellybeans and a bit
of few other so around 10 percent of
devices are still running KitKat so my
recommendation is like it still matters
10 percent is probably 200 million users
it's quite a big number so it still
matters but give it a couple of years
and hopefully in two years that will be
gone and now it can be part of this
museum all right
so things art matters for I've put eight
boxes they look nice and we do matter a
lot for this like if we do get it wrong
things will go bad on your device raw
performance I talked about that's Java
execution jank application startup
battery this space Ram boot times
install times I'm just repeating myself
but this is really important right this
is the thing that makes your user
experience kind of okay so that you can
enjoy the apps so I'm going to go over
the releases I talked about what what
different incarnations of the other at
one time to show what it brings to the
so what what makes art today because art
has a lot like I said a lot of
evolutions and but we also we also took
things from dalvik like good things from
dalvik I'm listing two major ones here
because the list would be too long and
obviously the major thing that that with
the dalvik architecture brought was RAM
savings and for that dalvik introduced
or dalvik or the android platform
actually introduced desire code which is
the parent process that creates all of
the other processes so because it's the
parent process you have the option of
that parent process starting up or
allocating a lot of memory for that apps
can use and that memory can be shared
with the other apps and that's super
important that means that every app now
doesn't need to allocate this memory
that it would need otherwise to actually
execute
in art today that's around like a couple
of dozens of megabyte that we save per
app and that the cycle just allocates
and share with the with the other apps
then lollipop that was the major shift
when we introduced ahead of time
compilation ahead of time compilation
happens with what we call an SSA
compiler static single assignment
compiler that's a compiler buzzword that
is like state of the art compiler that
does a lot of conversations and makes
your code up to 20x faster so we
introduced that ahead of time for polar
that helped a lot on reducing jank
because now the code was compiled not
needing to be interpreted very fast
reducing application startup same
argument but also saving battery like
now the execution being 20x faster you
can imagine that well it's not the point
of saving 20x times on your battery but
things get faster and and we don't need
to execute a lot on the CPU anymore we
also saved on boot times the whole
Android OS is ahead of time PayPal and
doesn't need to be interpreted at boot
so here we go things go faster at boot
we also introduced the new GCC
generational GC which reduce the pauses
and remove the need for GC for alloc in
dalvik then the third incarnation nuga
an oreo I mentioned how there will
introduced profile data compilation and
that thing helps it's kind of the mother
of all the optimizations today that we
do like it helps a lot of these metrics
it helps on in helps on Jack like less
code gets compiled the things that we
care about gets optimized so the UI
thread needs to run less code
it helps an application startup because
we can profile the application we're
able to know what matters at startup so
that we when we recompile the app we
will compile it with optimizations that
optimize startup you'll have some
battery again we're saving under the
amount of things we're interpreting
it'll have some disk space because
instead of compiling the entire app
which was which was was what lollipop
was doing now we're only compiling the
hot parts of an app that's probably like
10 to 20% of the decks code so 80% just
doesn't get compiled that's a lot of
savings seems on RAM having a current
GCE means we can do a lot more
fragmentation of the heaps of every app
so we save that on the fragmentation
that we had in a previous GC profile
compilation also helped a lot on boot
times remember the optimizing apps I log
or that's the reason we were able to
remove it now we didn't need to a ot
compiled at boot all of the apps to make
sure the device was reasonable in
performance we were we were able to just
okay we take a load ta we're gonna get
all the app so we don't need to compile
at boot we're gonna jet when the user
wants it and then eventually we're gonna
do profile guided compilation of the
apps when the user is not using its
phone and then finally it helping
install times because instead of waiting
for the compiler to compile the entire
app when you install now we didn't
compile at all
we'll just rely on the JIT the first
time the app was being used
and lastly I wanted to mention PI
because the the time we develop I was
kind of at the same time of Android go
and then it goes a great effort in the a
droid platform and for that we the work
we did was mostly to save on disk space
and RAM because Android goes like 512 to
a Giga bit of memory and for 8 gigs of
this space so most of our efforts were
focused on improving lamb and also
improving disk space so in that release
we introduced compact decks
which is like a compact version of the
text format which saves on RAM because
just the less you need to put into the
memory of the Dex code the more you're
saving obviously also when the apk has
uncompressed text in stored we will not
uncompress it on disk so before we
before we used to uncompress it to do
optimizations on the text file which we
cannot do in the apk because the apk is
signed so we aren't we before PI we are
compress it do some optimizations and
rely on them on the first few iterations
before we do profile gate compilation
now we give the option up to the
developer if the developer wants to save
on disk space then put the Dex file
uncompressed in dpk which means we're
not gonna uncompress it on device will
have just one version of the text code
and not a compressed version apk an
uncompressed one on disk alright that
was a lot of optimizations I wanted to
focus on one which is raw execution
performance because what you saw this
morning was pretty cool with the 18x but
this is even cooler
so obviously the faster are at once the
more we're sitting on battery an
application startup and make the UI
smooth so it really matters all the
optimizations we do
and over the releases we've gotten up
improving the performance by looking at
actual applications in this case it's
the Google sheets and every release we
worked on like okay how do we improve
the Google sheets app and the Google
sheets app or the Google sheets team
helped us build benchmarks that show
like how long it takes to do sheet
manipulation here higher is better Blue
is dalvik and that's a score of 1 so we
make it relative to dalvik the
performance readies lollipop so that's
when we introduced art and then yellow
is today and you can see that we went
from around like a 4x improvement when
we moved to art in lollipop to like an
average of 10x today and even 226 X on
one benchmark so we're pretty happy with
those numbers but we we just didn't look
just at Sheetz we try to also look at
what what happens to what happened to
other apps so a couple of years ago we
also look we also worked with the chrome
team and YouTube team to look at what
they think we should optimize and there
again like after the fact even though we
were not focused on optimizing those
benchmarks we saw that we had this 4 to
6 X improvements with what we've done
so there's tweaks to examples is the
octan benchmarks that's the JavaScript
benchmark suite that we poured it for
our purposes that's Delta blue enrichers
and it's again 2 to 4 X 3.5 X for those
benchmarks up to 6 X 2 n PI and then
exoplayer that's the audio and video
processor driving the YouTube app on
Android well again around 2 X 4 the
introduction of art and then 4 X to the
n pi
and one hour while I have your attention
on performance I have a sameness called
to do we always super interested in
improving code that you think is
important so if on your side you'd like
us to show off how we improve
performance of your app please come talk
to us there's the office hours from 1:00
to 6:00 this afternoon and we would be
really interested in knowing what you
think we should care about for
performance and then we can show that
off here all right so the question then
is like how did we get this level of
improvements I mentioned our art now has
a modern compiler implemented
I call that SSA and thanks to that
modern like SSA compilation
there's a bunch of optimizations we're
able to do now if you know compiler
while you things who could look familiar
lining dead code elimination I'm not
going to go over all of them lucky you
but instead I'll focus on an example
that shows how those optimizations
matter especially for language like
Cortland that puts a lot more
abstractions to help the protective
productivity of the user but makes it
more challenging for the runtime to
optimize all right so let's take this
simple method very simple it takes a
function that takes one argument and
then returns the length when we run that
to through our Dexter
r8 or awesomely Dexter here's the code
you you get again pretty straightforward
even if you from not familiar with text
code like you create a string then
constantly having non liberal types
you'll make sure that the string the
string is not know when you get it
passed to the function so the
as this helper method hey check that
this parameter is not know then invoke
vo to all of the length method on the
argument and return that
: comes with the built-in library so
that's where you can find
implementations of those helper methods
and for that case it's only like a
simple message that will just okay these
arguments no yes then I will throw
calling another helper or I will just
return and return it back to the method
so method calls are pretty expensive so
the first thing that art will do is that
it will try to inline that very small
method within the caller here the
compiler is inline it at the place is
being called just for simplicity reason
this looks like Dex code it's actually
the intermediate format of the compiler
but I'm not gonna show that to you
so compiled code is being inlined which
helps on performance but there's more we
can do because the compiler sees our way
that throw parameters is non exception
call it actually always throws so
there's a few things I can do with that
information first one is called cone
layout where we're trying to put
together like the regular flow of the
method so things that really happen we
put that at the very end of the method
so it doesn't affect the flow of the
execution nifty trick right we just
return we just switched to comparison
from a I do not zero to R u zero and
then we jump to the end of the method
which is like hey so an exception so the
expensive jump is that other picture now
the second optimization is that we're
going to move things that hey the
regular flow doesn't care about in this
case let me just go back if I can yeah
in this case the construction of the
string that is being passed to the
helper was the first thing your executor
in the method but you only need that if
you end up calling the helper so we move
that construction of that string that
string right before the helper meaning
we don't need to execute anymore
so in the end we started from a method
that was like creating a string calling
your helper then doing its thing which
is returning the length to a master that
just like check if it's no if it is jump
to an expensive job somewhere if it's
not just continue the flow and easy and
return the length of the method the
length of the string sorry all right so
that was raw performance I have two
other things to talk about
actually just one because have talked
about application startup and garbage
production but I'm not going to redo the
garbage collection side chat and remount
it a great job this morning so with
application startup it's a it's been a
major focus since we introduced profile
compilation and that happened in nuga
profile guerrilla compilation is when
when the app is being installed we
compile it in a very quick way like
we're not going to generate not going
like full alt compilation going to do
very little optimizations that do not
affect install time so optimizing
install time so the app is being
installed then you run it the app is
being executed initially it gets
executed with interpretation and then
method gets hot and then JIT kicks in
and compare those hot methods
the JIT knows what those hot methods are
so we are going to dump to a profile
foul those hot methods so that when your
device is idle the user is not using it
it's charging 100% charge then we have
this what we call profile guided daemon
that will just like okay let me walk
over all the profiles and recompile the
app and compile them compiled only the
things that matter based on that profile
and you have like this virtuous loop
where the next time you run the app
that's we're gonna use that optimized
version of the compiled code and then
run it with what's got a o teed maybe
some methods got missed so will
interpret them they'll get hot will
cheat them will update the profile and
then again the demon kicks in say oh the
profile got updated let me recompile the
app so this is this virtuous loop of
like trying to be better and better over
time and why is that helping an
application startup well that's because
the the things we do when we compile the
app based low profile are really
optimized towards this we are only going
to compute sorry we're going to compile
startup methods so now no need to
interpret them things that get executed
at startup will get compiled we're going
to lay out the Dex and the compiled code
so things that execute our startup will
be next to each other so now we don't
need to jump over the entire Dex file to
actually get access to the method and
that's very important like I said ABS
got bigger so if you need to bring up
the entire text file just for start-up
that's a lot of time waiting on i/o so
we're trying to reduce that by putting
everything on startup at the beginning
and then the rest at the end
profile compilation also generates an
application image other runtimes will
call this a snapshot it's a
representation of Java classes that we
put in that image it's a file and that
avoids us to actually load the classes
at runtime again so there's this there's
this pre formatted number of classes
with a class order and when we start up
we just take the class order all the
classes are already populated and we're
done no need to do cut code class
learning anymore we also want to try to
pre initialize classes so Java has the
step of Lycos classes need to be
initialized before they need to be
executed so what we do during profile
compilation is that we're going to pre
initialize anything we can to avoid that
being executed when we start the app and
then finally I said when I got a
compiled code that doesn't get executed
that helps a lot because then your old
file is very small your sorry your
compiled file is very small so there's
not a lot you need to bring up in memory
to actually execute what do we gain from
all those optimizations where they can
be we always gain doing those
optimizations but depending on the app
that can be under at the ten percent or
30 percent and that's usually around how
many Java code
do you have when you start your app
typically camera has a lot of native
code so that's where it's on the low end
of like 10% improvement but in this
example you see dogs and maps which are
very Java heavy go from around 30% of AB
start up improvement
and this is numbers that we got from the
Maps team who got that from actual users
so actual data that comes from the field
and when it's the Maps team so like
graph they were like what is going on
how come I'd install things are around
like a one second of app startup to over
time as things get faster how does that
happen and every time the update the app
it's the same trend it starts pretty
high and then goes low and the answer is
profile computation here you're clearly
seeing that over time things get better
today in PI what we've talked about i/o
last year is the introduction of
profiles in the cloud and that's how
we're making the entire ecosystem send
us profiles like actual execution
profiles of users so that we can send
those profiles to new users of app so
they don't get this starts at one second
ends up at seven fifty milliseconds to
get the 750 million seconds right away
because they get the profile at the
point install
garbage collection like I said I'm not
going over them over it maybe I can just
put back a number that we're all very
proud of here we are
ah that's the last so this is resuming
what Chad talks about this morning it's
all the technology we've used over time
for building a GC so you see in KitKat
we had this what we call kirker
mark-sweep it was one part of the GC
that was concurrent and that stayed for
up until nuga in Oreo that's when we
introduced concurrent collector
allocation KitKat it was the main
bottleneck and it was single threaded so
need to lock to actually allocate
something the instructor introduction of
a new GC in lollipop meant that we could
allocate within the sweat and not need a
lock so that improve performance of
allocation the when you allocate objects
are short-lived right and that's the
motto of of Java it's like feel free to
allocate objects so one of our short
live will be remover to GC very quickly
but in KitKat in davic days I was not
the case it was you had you pay a very
high cost by allocating temporary
objects lollipop is when we introduce a
new GC and you didn't pay the cost at
all like allocating short-lived object
was we had generations so things were
removed pretty quickly there's an
asterisk for Oreo because when we
introduce concurrent collector we remove
the generations out of the of the
collector we're fixing that today it's
in the OSP the improvement of the GC
with generations so hopefully we'll be
there the device soon
and our fragmentation fragmentation is a
big problem in android because if you're
not able to allocate memory your app
will be killed so doing compaction of
the memory so that things are not
fragmented is super important
KitKat did a bit but very little in
lolly part of a marshmallow we were
doing it when the app was going
background so eventually we're
reclaiming the memory but Oreo is when
we made it like it's really important
that we compact all the time so that the
memory is there available all the time
and then the number I was looking for
allocation speed we went from a very low
number in dalvik to an 18 X improvement
in Oreo and Pi and it was thirsty the
reasons we the reasons it got improved
lollipop added a custom a locator I did
not need to lock that in marshmallow we
had fewer caste operations that atomic
operations that that have a cost but we
were able to remove a bit of them then
all of that all of that implementation
of the allocation path was moved to
assembly code in nuga which made things
even faster and then finally in android
oreo we ever we implemented bomb pointer
allocation which meant the only thing
you do when you allocate is increment
increment a pointer all right with that
this is the recommendation that Chet has
and that comes from us so I'll give the
same creating garbage is okay today you
can use a type and allocate objects you
need GC is still overhead so be mindful
that if you allocate a lot of objects
and GC will need to run but it's less
less a problem since dalvik
and with that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]